I claimed actor Brian Cranston will stop
gracing our screens in a few years but
it's for the nicest possible reason
I'm done in an interview with a British
GQ promoting his latest film asteroid
City Cranston revealed that he's gonna
take a step back from magding in 2026 so
that he can devote more time to his wife
of 34 years Robin dearden apparently has
a specific plan in mind he's going to
shutter his production company as a move
to a foreign country possibly France for
as long as he can with deerden the actor
will also turn 70 that year he told GQ I
want to change the Paradigm once again
for the last 24 years Robin has led her
life holding onto my tail she's been the
plus one she's been the wife of a
celebrity she's had to Pivot and adjust
her life based on mine she has
tremendous benefit from it but we're
uneven I want to level that out she
deserves it Cranston told the magazine
he wants to enjoy a different lifestyle
where he can explore new places Cozier
by the fireplace and sip of wine with
new friends